it's a celebration as demi lovato turns
the big 3-0
it's a good decade it's the best it's
going into you know the era of being so
sure of yourself
[Applause]
the confident singer kicked off a
star-studded birthday bash by partying
with her a-list pals and judging from
the dance floor it looks like the place
to be at
yep paris hilton danced the night away
with her longtime pal to gwen stefani
sweet escape exactly we stick together
and as paris put it the two were
hashtags living slaying and living their
best life
kristen stewart and ashley benson also
stepped out to celebrate demi's big day
but no one was more supportive and silly
than demi's boyfriend jute dollar who
appeared to be the life of the party
a highlight of demi's night watching
jute and her friend michael wilde out to
holla back girl i had fun of course her
man's heartfelt birthday tribute got a
pretty big reaction as well
jude dollar wrote i'm the luckiest
schmuck in the world cause i get to call
you mine making you laugh has become my
new obsession
[Music]
he continued to praise the singer for
her growth after years of battling
addiction something demi's been candid
about with e.t breaking up with my old
self and my addiction and my alcoholism
i'm so proud of you for not only
surviving everything you've been through
but coming out on top and becoming your
healthiest happiest sweetest self demi
reacted in the comments writing you're
the best boyfriend in the world
[Music]
[Applause]
nothing screams birthday like a sweet
cake e.t surprised demi a few days ahead
of her milestone b day with a cake of
our own
[Music]
celebration comes on the heels of her
major music drop her pop punk album holy
is out now
[Music]
and during her tour rehearsal she got
real with us reflecting on the biggest
lesson she's learned over the last 30
years staying true to who i am growing
um finding my own voice is was really
important to me and now now i understand
that i am in control of my life i make
my own decisions and i'm my own boss
[Music]